do the handshake
the Paranormal war is Big Business we'll
enchant you must now discuss your
astonishing experiences as paranormal
soldiers in the ongoing paranormal Wars
this is ghosted the Paranormal Wars
begin
what I don't know quite what Dee is
talking about here are okay well there's
also you know when every time
doozy it seems has something that wants
us to talk about but doesn't quite know
what to refer to it as it ends up being
called game slimers right we do it this
is not that though this is the this
could be
um what paranormal war is there a
paranormal War happening that uh yeah
dude always constantly I can't believe
you don't know about this
um have you ever had a ghost experience
who me yeah dude no I've never I've no
wait have you ever heard ghost classic
ghost yeah dude I have really yeah like
a real one real one dude first person
really uh yes I will tell you it now I
don't know if I've ever told you the
story actually it requires a little bit
of backstory my mom and dad grew up in
this little town no offense
called Great Bend Kansas oh that is a
alone directly in the
middle of the state I've never been a
very small population Etc but my mom
when she was growing up as a little kid
was friends with this woman or another
little kid whose family owned a bunch of
jewelry stores in and around the town
and they lived in this kind of big old
house that was built you know
turn of the century back in the day and
it was a mansion and it was rumored that
this the guy who owned it before them
was named Mr Moses and it was rumored
that this motherfucker's Spirit haunted
this place and they all had stories of
you know the the mom of the house
wouldn't be able to find some receipts
or whatever and she'd be like Mr Moses
can you help us find these receipts and
then the next day they'd just be on her
desk like this right they
had all kinds of creepy stories like
this my mom had a firsthand tale that
she and the little girl she was friends
with she would spend the night over
there and they went in the
kitchen and all the cupboards start
opening and closing right and so my
sister and I our whole lives are like uh
whatever is or mom's
lying to us
um and then when I'm in college this is
my first couple years of college my
sister was still in high school we go
back to Great Bend for a Christmas to
visit our grandparents and me and my
sister get up my mom's ass and are like
get your friend to take us in
that house and give us a tour we want to
see Mr Moses and at this point
nobody lived in the house the family
still owned it but it was empty
they had some furniture and in
there but with like you know drop cloths
on and stuff like that so we go back and
indeed my mom's friend uh is like yeah
sure I'll show you around so we go in
old ass creaking door and
lights are still getting flipped on so
there's still electricity and we
basically come to this thing she's
showing us the living room the
downstairs this that whatever we come to
the staircase that goes up and at the
top of the staircase it's kind of a
little walkway at the end of one uh
piece of the walkway is a door at the
end of the other walkways a door and
then there's two doors kind of in the
wall that faces you and these were
bedrooms of the kids
so we go up there we go into the far
left room open the door she turns on the
light this is where Jimmy slept or
whatever
turns off a light closes the door
we go into each of those three doors
when we get to the final one we come out
of it and we're facing the first one we
went into and the door is open
and the light is on holy
yeah dude and uh I just recently talked
to my sister about this I was like am I
remembering that right did that
happen and she's like yeah I
think about it every day
uh that was my first hand experience of
this I'm not lying about this at
all we still have no idea like there's a
piece of me that kind of tries to
rationalize it like oh she was probably
just with us you know my mom's
friend like trying to scare us or
whatever but she was with us the whole
time she definitely did not go back and
open that door and turn on that light
you're talking about seeing ghosts yeah
and Mr Moses Mr Moses this story is
insane but have you ever
considered we already said you know the
computer simulation thing but have you
ever considered that these are
interdimensional beings sure and and
interdimensional beings there's only one
there's uh we're in we're
three-dimensional we're living in in
three-dimensional yeah world but NASA
you know has proven through uh uh uh
spectrometers or specterometers that
there's Dark Matter five times uh more
powerful and then ours and and uh
interdimensional beings are going back
and forth as I like to say if you want
to bring sharks to the surface you chum
the waters yeah and these
interdimensional beings and demons they
want uh the coin so if you sacrifice oh
my God virgins and children as we have
in the Babylonian times mesoamericans
did it uh and and the Germans did it and
it laid waste in genocide then the
demons go oh you don't give a about
anybody then you can see more things so
maybe you are uh you might be a soldier
in the Paranormal War Jed you might be
seeing things that other people don't
and not just because you're you know at
the bottom of a bottle of wild turkey
you don't drink no not anymore I loved I
love I love whiskey yeah I love vodka I
love tequila and and uh
bourbon which is also whiskey yeah I
like Scotch which is whiskey I like
Japanese whiskey Japanese Scotch okay
gin yeah uh Mr Moses speaking of coin
was reported to have left a gift under
the Christmas tree for this family one
year that were was these uh coins that
were minted in the year he died
this is why the head of Bank of America
said that we are uh you know we're the
whim of dark Forces okay
so Mr Moses have you what do you think
of any of this what do you think of
ghost stories paranormal what have you
um I think that ghosts absolutely exist
and I don't know where they're stuck but
I I totally I totally believe it the
only time
I ever experienced anything uh in the
same
sort of way that that you have I didn't
I nothing happened but someone was
trying to convince us that something was
there was this paranormal expert that
was friends with Deborah Wilson on Mad
TV and they used to say that the old
Hollywood center studios were haunted so
uh one night literally after the show
Deb was like whoever wants to come with
us you know Peter his name was Peter he
was on all his TV shows about the
and he took us on a little tour and
there was a story about how these two
workers were up in the um up in like the
rafters of this one Sound Stage and this
one has been around since the 1930s this
uh there's like this beautiful old sort
of white house looking Victorian style
house out in the front and uh that there
was a couple of workers who fell to
their death and then one day a security
guard was chasing two workers at night
he's like what are you guys doing here
and they went through a wall apparently
so we walked into that sound stage and
he's like put your hand in here it's
cold in here that's a portal to a
different dimension and I was like nope
and then we heard something drop over
somewhere nothing yeah but I do think
that
um you know
spirits and souls
have a way to to talk with us and and
you know most people say that if they're
tortured or their story on Earth wasn't
didn't come to the uh right ending that
they stick around looking for more I I
think that makes perfect sense see Chad
I'm a really open-minded guy yeah and
you think that I'm just like nope AI is
this and dudes he has to be your friend
in order for you to uh deal with
them and stuff but that's not true I'm a
very open-minded guy I know that lulio
talks to me but I don't know
necessarily but I do think that we know
very little about human consciousness we
know very little about reality as a
whole and certainly we know very little
little about the Persistence of human
consciousness after what we perceive to
be death
it does that ultimately equate to like
spirits and ghosts and hauntings and
I think that's kind of how we've
made sense of it in the more rudimentary
era of human understanding of this
but I think we are getting to a place
now where it's it's opening up a little
bit what are the Paranormal Wars then
that I don't know you have to ask your
buddy D about that one D what is the
Paranormal word I mean Chad you said
that you you told the story about how
you were at war with Mr Moses I wasn't
at war with it well that was a battle
yes it was and we are all
interdimensional soldiers can also be
something to do with time dude I I mean
we know that time is or a different time
dude yes exactly we know that time isn't
linear so it could be a thing that Mr
Moses is somehow existing in the time
that he was in quotes alive but that
time has overlapped with where we are
now so that these Spirits in quotes can
interact with things in other times and
maybe after you die that's what your
Consciousness is it gets freed to kind
of exist in multiple times
simultaneously as we believe uh most
stuff actually does but and and it also
might be the observer effect which If
You observe a matter enough it it
changes it moves okay and perhaps you
want to see those ghosts I did that's
why we went there yeah Well Chad claims
to live in the fourth dimension which is
impossible I've never made that clinic I
think Nancy Pelosi probably ends up oh
God she's like a she's like a character
five levels down in a video game okay
she's got herself entrenched yeah you've
been playing Hogwarts Legacy dude yep I
love Hogwarts Legacy I do too I
love Hogwarts uh bourbon oh
butter beer they got in Hogwarts beer
butter and Hogwarts you're talking about
any of the Harry Potter movies
give a about no Harry Potter movie
got dragged to one and I was like why so
angry about it
because I'm angry about it what do you
mean but like why all that why
why all that because I don't
care about that right okay I guess
that's it no I've never seen I've never
seen uh I've never seen but wait a
minute I love Harry Potter
movies Harry Potter has beer in the
movie they got this in the video that
the little kids drink yeah see and
you're you're saying alcoholic I think
it's more like root beer oh well
then never mind I was gonna draw a
parallel to RoboCop Saturday morning
cartoon and Rambo sending an arrow right
through someone's skull I miss
the 80s man yeah Harry Potter gets down
he kills people
or Voldemort kills people Cedric
Diggory uh Robert Pattinson he
got nailed by Voldemort
one of the movies
wasn't that violent though
thank you moving on please
here
please tell the friends
[Music]